[Music]
as many as half of Earth's species may
be already migrating to escape warming
temperatures plants are inching
northward and so are many animals the
Arctic ecosystem is particularly
vulnerable to invasion
[Music]
scientists aboard this research ship are
hunting the most important fish in the
Arctic polar cod mixed in with the
Arctic fish are invaders including
Atlantic cod and capelin the Saturn
species compete for polar cards food
there's a balmy from the north an army
for the south and they they fight the
battle at the moment it is the army for
himself that is really expanding so we
use a very typical Arctic food web or
food chain this food web is changing now
these fish are among many species
migrating into the warming Arctic
relatively few species have evolved to
survive its frigid darkness polar cod
have some of the most impressive
adaptations to survive they have
antifreeze proteins so compounds that
kind of make them be able to live in
water that is below zero temperatures
they use a trick that's common among
arctic animals they store lots of fat in
their bodies polar cod eat tiny copepods
which also store fat to survive the long
winter the most important zooplankton
species in the Arctic they convert the
algae diet to lipids and they start in
their body as the in this form of lipid
section which makes them a very high
energy source or as a prey item for a
higher predators and a high energy meal
is crucial for surviving the harsh
Arctic one trawl after another reveals
southern interlopers
out of a thousand fish caught in the
straw
roughly 70% by weight our southern
species it's hard for the scientists to
pinpoint precisely when we cross the
boundary between Atlantic and Arctic
waters but that boundary has been slowly
creeping northward scientists call this
process the Atlanta fication of the
Arctic Atlantic waters are saltier and
they mostly lack ice the biggest
difference
Atlantic water is as much as seven
degrees warmer the polar Cod likes the
colder water but it's losing territory
they have an imitation in the north and
the heavy limitation of the south polar
cod flourish in the shallow waters of
the Bering Sea but further north it's
too deep for them Sullenberger is
personal
their habitat is shrinking meanwhile the
warmer waters bring with them new
species that are shaking up the food
wind along with new fish there are
Atlantic varieties of copepods they
store much less fat than copepods native
to the Arctic making them a less
nutritious food source that means polar
cod may have to spend more energy
hunting for the same amount of transfer
the same amount of energy
capelin as well as atlantic cod were
among the invaders we just caught in the
trawl Midland will also feed on the same
tree and the polar cubs so we start
adding competition between these two
species the Atlantic cod goes one step
further it eats the polar cod itself
humans are as rich as polar cuts so if
that goes our diminishes and these
levels will also be impacted
it's easy to vilify the southern species
threatening the ecological balance here
but take the Atlantic cog in their
natural habitat overfishing and now
rising temperatures have decimated its
population so here in the Arctic
Atlantic cod seems like an invader
but it's also a climate refugee from the
south and its main predator is another
key species advancing northward the most
important southern invader into the
Arctic might be us humans why did you
press the native knowledge of course to
look for copepods and tried to plankton
and see what they're doing
[Music]
historically most humans who have come
to the Arctic have taken a lot more than
data and a few samples for at least
forty five thousand years people have
been coming to this paradoxical region
punishing desolate but rich with
resources humans are the Arctic's
ultimate apex predator and yet we're
only getting started
with countries like Norway extracting
fossil fuels offshore other sectors are
also expanding northward from tourism to
shipping to military operations so the
stressors in the Arctic are probably
going to intensify as the climate here
changes so will the meaning of the word
Arctic for the animals who for now call
it home
[Music]
[Music]
you